627 on your wednesday morning everybody
we're throwing some shade at those wide
open spaces
between cars at stoplights and we're
doing it literally so in all the years
we've been doing driving you crazy the
only other topic that comes close to the
responses about spaces between cars and
stop lights it's been the outrage over
cars with expired plates or even scarier
no plates and i still want to hear from
metro for more about that but got a few
more highlights from the dozens and
dozens of emails about cars and distance
and stop lights that includes
motorcyclist rod who writes the light
turns red and all of a sudden it's time
to read that text he applauds drivers
for at least not trying to read or reply
as they drive and he closes with i may
not wear a bow tie like you nate but i
always wear a helmet even in the heat
thank you so much then there's brad who
looks at the financial implications a
car hits you from behind causing you to
hit the person in front of you making
you buy that person a new car
who knows if the the guy that hit you
has insurance to fix your car or your
front person's car
do you have thousands of dollars to buy
the guy in front of you a car and pay
seventy thousand dollars for their
medical bills finally for now rob writes
it's all about waiting in the shade when
possible under the hot sun why not wait
under an overpass he writes my vehicle
stays cooler by 20 degrees buildings
trees underpasses any shade when it's
blazing away in temps like sitting in a
furnace even with the air conditioning
thanks to ron brad rob and all of you
who emailed i hope you don't mind my
staying with this subject at least one
more time because i got a few more
emails to share next week buckle up
drive carefully please put down that
phone if there is something driving you
crazy the email address is traffic eight
at eight news now dot